this is a production of cornell
university
uh julie is the fruit ipm coordinator
with cornell's cooperative extension's
new york state ipm program she holds a
phd in plant pathology and plant
molecular biology from a university
cornell university okay
and an ms from university of
massachusetts and a bs in botany from
the university of maine her job as a
fruit ipm coordinator is deliver ipm
knowledge to fruit growers and develop
ways for them to adopt ipm so that they
can help grow healthy fruit crops with
minimal pesticide inputs on a personal
level julie and i have been
collaborators since my first day in
cornell and back in 2006 she's been an
important mentor for all my extension
and applied research endeavors
throughout my entire career working
together as a team we've been able to
greatly improve the disease forecasting
systems for apple and the newa system
we've worked so much on really doing a
lot to improve the fruit production
guidelines
pesticide database systems and um
greatly enhanced all the
outreach and the reach and the success
of my uh anti-microbial resistance
surveys for numerous fruit pathogens
finally
even though she'd uh mentioned wanting
to do this back in 2006 we finally
completed those fact sheet redrafts and
we did it with feeling without any
further ado let's welcome julie to
present her story on dutch elm disease
to hummingbirds a woman's guide to plant
pathology
thank you so much carrick and thank you
all for being here
um so let's get started
a little bit about me
so i lived in about 10 places growing up
went to eight schools k through 12. i
actually finished high school
as a junior
my dad was in the air force i was born
in little rock arkansas which is like
right here
and then we moved to
uh wichita falls texas and then to
clinton oklahoma that's why you learned
how to ride horses
and then we
moved to upper peninsula michigan
and that's why i learned how to toboggan
wow that is a lot of fun
we moved from there to fairfax virginia
where i learned some
diplomacy and from there we zoomed down
to central america we lived in guatemala
city for three and a half years where i
was the fastest freestyle swimmer for
all of those years
in guatemala
and then from there we moved to
tegucigalpa honduras
from there my dad was transferred oh
no all the way up to loring air force
base
maine which is a decommissioned air
force base at this point in time so uh
and that was in march pretty cold up
there compared to tegucigalpa
so uh finished
high school and went to
get my bachelor's in oreno
and then master's degree at umass and
after that i landed a job at cornell
ithaca as the diagnostician and 4-h
specialist
after a few years there i got a phd in
plant pathology
after that i did some freelancing for
aps k through 12 enrichment in a program
we were calling at the time plant
pathways to science
and then i did a couple post docs at
agritech in geneva and then landed the
fruit ipm coordinator job in
2001
so at umaine
i was able to learn about dutch elm
disease in high school i learned that
american elves had a disease
and i had to help them
i love trees
dr richard campana had a successful
integrated management program for dutch
owned disease and i worked with him and
his phd student at the time janet
anderson
the integrated program basically
involved spraying for bark beetles
the vectors of the fungus surveying for
strikes which are
branches that you can see up in the
crown of the trees that are wilting and
turning yellow
injecting infected trees or even
prophylactically with systemic
fungicides
around the trunk
and that was the research that janet was
involved with on the microorganisms that
were colonizing those injection wounds
and i helped her with that work
another aspect of controlling this
disease involves destroying root grafts
because the fungus can travel down the
xylem vessels into
the roots and into another adjacent
american elm that has a root craft with
it
and then of course removing dying and
dead trees
this picture is the campana elm named in
honor of dick campana the campana elm is
still alive today at the university of
maine campus
and their website says that it may be
older than the university itself
and did you guys know
that a dutch group of scientists
elucidated this disease
there are no dutch elms that grow no
it's called dutch elm disease because
of the dutch scientists and a dutch
woman scientist marie beatrice schwartz
isolated the fungus from diseased elms
in europe and proved it to be the cause
of the disease
a little over a hundred years ago
over 40 million american elms have died
from this disease in the u.s
i went on to study maple decline at the
university of massachusetts with dr
terry tatter in the shade trade
laboratories
and what i was doing was correlating
root starch as shown by these iodine
stains
with tree crown condition
this crown is healthy and this crown is
in severe decline
and what we were trying to do is to
develop an easy assay that urban
foresters could use to gauge tree health
and this would aid their decisions on
whether to
literally just remove this tree or do
pruning
in the crown to remove the dead and
dying branches
and then fertilize it and try to bring
it back
here you can see a root cross section
stained with iodine
that has
tons of starch
so it would be high
and here you have low
to depleted starch in the wood of the
tree now all woody plants store
carbohydrate in their roots primarily
over the winter
and so it's a really great way to know
how healthy the plants are they mobilize
this starch in the spring as buds start
to grow
and
up until the leaves
are photosynthetically active
that stored starch is what the trees are
relying on
and even such plants as grapevines
and you can see here the correlation
that we found between tree crown
condition and root starch content
uh-oh i think i'm doing
what carrick was saying
[Music]
let's wait for the program to respond
so then slide i'm going to show you
about
the insect and plant disease diagnostic
lab at cornell university
here i am on a typical summer day in the
lab
with all these plant samples this was a
little growth chamber area i created on
a work
on a bookcase and here i am surrounded
with plant materials
yellow walls you might ask
well
before i moved into this lab the walls
were painted yellow because it was
thought that that color was more
pleasant for a woman
and it's interesting the way things have
changed a little bit for women over the
last
40 years since i've been here at cornell
but those cheery walls brightened my
days
on innumerable years as i was working in
the diagnostic lab
so here are some statistics for you for
1987.
and i ex i expect sandy can relate to
this
so i got approximately 1500 total
inquiries
that year
about 1300 of those were actually
samples that needed to be diagnosed
845 of those proved to be biotic
diseases
and the remainder of 400 or so abiotic
diseases
in addition i received 43 letters and
yes these were letters on paper in an
envelope with a postage stamp delivered
by the us post office
and i had to decipher the handwriting on
some of those letters and i became very
good at it over the years
we also got in 14 mushrooms for
identification and 71 phone calls
you know 71 phone calls that's nothing
compared to the likely number of email
inquiries that are being fielded these
days by the plant disease diagnostic lab
in plant pathology
some interesting finds
alfalfa mosaic came in on this swedish
ivy plant
causing these etched
ring patterns and rosie providenti at
the geneva
campus then called the ag experiment
station
helped me identify this disease and we
published a plant disease note
early days i think it was probably 1982
or so i got this persian violet sample
in
and it had this die back i actually
propagated it and thought oh i can take
some of these home which i was often
doing bringing rescue plants home to
plant
as houseplants or in my yard
but every single one of those cuttings
that rooted all of them died of this
disease and it turned out to be a tospo
virus what is now known as impatience
necrotic spot virus on this persian
violet plant
a quarantine level disease we handled a
lot was bacterial blight of geranium
so let's look at the clientele
most of the samples that i would get in
were from cornell cooperative extension
people
and then from horticultural inspectors
those are the people that would send me
these bacterial blight
samples we also got things directly in
from homeowners about 145 of the total
for 1987.
and then 203 commercial
samples would come in potentially from
turf grass managers you can see turf
grass samples here
or from um
white flower farm in connecticut that
type of thing
and then 41 of those samples were from
people on campus sometimes researchers
who had diseases that were affecting
their subject plants that they were
doing experiments with
most of the commodities that we got in
were woody ornamentals which was good
for me because of my background in woody
plants
then florist and foliage followed by
field crops
then
vegetables and herbs
or herbs sorry about that and then turf
grass
and fruits
ironically i work in fruits now and
those were the lowest numbers that we
would get samples of
of course the overwhelming majority of
the biotic diseases were caused by fungi
then followed by bacteria with 97
40 that year were viruses and then
interestingly
four were phytoplasma
three
were nematodes and two were parasitic
plants
during that time i also was the 4-h
plant pathology specialist for cornell
and this allowed me to interact with
people who were doing programs for kids
and also with the kids themselves
and i really pride myself on increasing
the participation in plant pathology
projects during the years that i was
working in 4-h for the department
we typically saw the highest 4-h
participation associated with 4-h
projects that involved schools
like the sick talking plant project that
was developed by my predecessor wix
westcott
and here i am in a tr in one of these
teacher training sessions
showing them all how to do some of the
associated exercises that went along
with the sick talking plant project
these 4-h project bulletins were ones
that i either developed from scratch
know your plan know your plants disease
and know your tree diseases and i also
revised the fun with fungi bulletin
here's an activity that was in know your
plants diseases find the plant disease
symptoms
and of course it's an apple tree with
just about every symptom known to human
beings
probably one of the most exciting things
that i did
was i increased participation
in the fun with fungi project
during a cornell cooperative extension
regional in-service education program
we would travel across the state and
meet with the 4-h
agents in each county in different
regions and people told me oh julie
you'll never be able to get that person
to do
fun with fungi or anything plant
pathology he only does horse programs in
4-h
aha well i knew how to ride and so i
said to him i said well you know
how about practicing dismounting and
remounting while keeping the horse under
control and
collecting
mushrooms while you're out on the trail
and sure enough
that year
he did just that with his 4-h
and ended up sending mushroom
collections
to the state fair for exhibits so every
year we would rate
exhibits at the state fair and this
happens to be an exhibit that i
developed
and
i took uh vivian meow
a graduate student at the time and
srirama bailly a postdoc at the time
with me to state fair so they could
experience the new york state fair
with me
after the diagnostic lab i took time off
and i got a phd
on wheat spill a streak mosaic virus
and that was with dr gary bergstrom and
dr stuart gray
who was in the virology and nematology
lab so most of my work was in the vn lab
here's the gary bergstrom program at the
time
gary
me much younger of course both of us
and a couple of his graduate students
this technician and a visiting scientist
at the time
and this is the directory of the vm lab
that my son decided the vn lab needed
because it did not have a pictorial
staff directory like
the plant science department had so he
created these images of all of the
vienna scientists
so during that time this is a picture of
the disease it's a great picture that
gary took
um i'm i've been and will continue to be
fascinated by virus symptoms on plants
we created a whosomvi antiserum
we documented the natural cycle
infection of winter wheat it's a soil
borne virus that infects over the winter
and then movement into the leaves occurs
in the spring and symptom expression
later on
i also advanced the understanding of
virus resistance in winter wheat through
mechanical and soil inoculations of
different wheat breeding lines and
cultivars with known resistance levels
we grew the putative vector
polymixograminus
in exotic culture in a flooding system
but unfortunately i was unsuccessful in
transmitting the virus with the
zoospores of this organism polymix
agraminus
here's a
electron micrograph of the purified
wssmv preparation here i am collecting
samples
in the winter time and this is my son
helping me interpret my scientific data
after my phd
i took some time off because actually
when i was defending my phd
i was so pregnant with my twins that i
think the people in my committee meeting
were a little bit quite nervous about
the whole thing because i was really
quite big
and after that the cost of daycare was
essentially prohibitive and it really
didn't make sense to put two babies
and a seven-year-old into daycare and
have only about fifty dollars left per
week
but in any case
i did some freelance work for aps on
k-12 enrichment during that time
and also worked for the national
association of biology teachers on
developing a monograph titled learning
biology with plant pathology
my colleagues on the youth programs
committee of aps this
committee is no longer active
helped me with the exercises in this
monograph
and here i am at the nabt meeting we had
an aps booth at that meeting
and we also at the national aps meetings
would have teacher enrichment programs
at each meeting
again we were trying to get a teacher
training effort going based at cornell
university called plant pathways to
science but it was not selected for
funding by nsf unfortunately
and here i am interacting with
this
children of faculty and postdocs
in
basically testing out some of these
approaches to
teaching plant pathology to younger
audiences
after that
i did a postdoc with dr wayne wilcox up
in geneva i also did another postdoc
after this one with georgia bowie but
i'm not going to go into any of the data
from that that was on carrot leaf
blights
this postdoc focused on grapevine
powdery mildew and we did four different
projects for this
this particular project
was probably
the most well known
um it studied the effect of relative
humidity
on grapevine powdery mildew development
we found 85 percent relative humidity as
the optimum
we use saturated salt solutions in these
growth chambers inside a growth room
wherein air was pumped through water
through the saturated salt and into the
chamber
and a data logger tracked the
temperature and relative humidity inside
the chamber during the run of the
experiment
we found that as rh increases relative
humidity and we also looked at absolute
humidity and vapor pressure deficit and
the results are essentially the same
severity increases
up to about 85 percent
disease sporulation intensity increases
up to about 85 percent disease incidence
also increased i'm not showing those
data slides and then spore germination
increased as well this
experiment was done on microscope slides
and then up to about 85 percent relative
humidity
and after that
germination declined precipitously
we also looked at a disease severity
gradient next to lake erie
here's the cliff face next to lake erie
and here are the oak trees on the edge
of that cliff face and here's the
vineyard moving away from the lake
we had data loggers positioned
in and along five different plots moving
away from the lake with pot plot one
being closest plot five being furthest
from the lake
basically three fold higher cluster
powdery mildew disease severity as you
can see in this slide
would occur closer to lake erie
in plot 1 as compared to plot 5.
we've found that from pre-bloom to five
millimeter berry size the time when the
cluster the fruit is at greatest risk of
infection its susceptibility is highest
for pathogen infection
that it was warmer during the day
closer to the lake here's zero
difference
and here's about half a degree
difference
all day long closer to the lake and then
at sunset
that temperature difference dropped
significantly and very quickly so that
it was one degree colder
closer to the lake which of course those
of you who understand relative humidity
means that there's a spike in relative
humidity
closer to the lake compared to further
away
we also looked at two fungicides
monopotassium phosphate and jms styled
oil we wanted to know what the mode of
action of mono-potassium phosphate was
and we wanted to know the effect of jms
style oil on bricks
so we used for the monopotassium
phosphate experiment using exclusion
chambers that scrubbed the air in the
greenhouse
before
pushing that air through these chambers
any of you who have grown plants that
are susceptible to powdery mildew in a
greenhouse setting know that it is
everywhere powdery mildew
loves greenhouse conditions
and here you can see plants that were
taken out of those chambers
chardonnay sprayed three days after
inoculation with mkp
has no
powdery mildew
whereas
the vines sprayed with water
have powdery mildew colonies developing
on the inoculated leaves
so we found that monopotassium phosphate
is an erratican at three to seven days
post-inoculation
that it had no protected activity
and it also had anti-surveillant
activity although i'm not sharing those
data with you right now
my twin daughters decided that they were
going to check out these exclusion
chambers so that they could show you
at the time i took this picture how big
these exclusion chambers were so they're
about big enough to fit in a
three-year-old toddler
in terms of jms styled oil and its
effect on bricks we found that late
season sprays with this material could
reduce bricks by one degree
but that early season sprays do not
those of you who make wine or who grow
wine grapes or even juice grapes know
that one degree brix can be really
significant especially in our climate it
can be a make or break as to whether
your grapes may be accepted at a
processor
it's basically determining the soluble
solids in the grapes which is correlated
with carbohydrate content or sugars
all of the fungicides in this trial
reduced the number of chasmothesia
formed
on the leaf surfaces
and i chose to regress all of that
disease severity data that i had against
the number of cosmothesia
the name was changed from close to the
sierra cosmothesia during the interim of
when i did this work and today so i'm
trying to
you know use the updated
language for this
but it basically showed this regression
analysis that as little as four percent
levary infected
could lead to
fully formed cosmeticia on the leaf
surface
indicating that it's pretty tough to
prevent that life cycle of powdery
mildew from moving forward year to year
then on to the new york state ipm
program i have worked 20 phenomenal
years in fruit ipm
the ipm program is an exceptional
program with exceptionally talented
people and a fun place to work here i am
in the year when i started working there
this is a picture taken of our program
um not too many years ago
nicely dominated by women
this is my technician
one of the field technicians that i had
nicole mattoon and were checking
traps in an apple orchard
and this is what
your
program can do with cool pictures when
you're all away at the ipm symposium and
it's just the webmaster who's a great
graphic designer left with uh folks in
the lab
so one of the first things i did
when i got my job in ipm was i went out
and i talked to growers to find out okay
what are your needs what are the key
things that are happening for you
related to ipm
and at one of these
an apple grower said i need cornell to
create a program
that can
fill out all of the processor forms with
my spray records that i have to fill out
every year
before i can sell my fruit to anybody
and i
just laughed and i said well you know
i
not a programmer i don't think i can do
that
but
when i took
these results from all these visits
across the state back to the ipm
director at the time
mike hoffman
he said
that's what you should do and here's
twenty thousand dollars go do it
so
we did
um i hired a technician judy nedrow at
the time to help me develop this
software and we did absolutely develop
it and it is able to do exactly what the
grower wanted and more
indeed
at a
presentation i was giving last week
the growers in the audience said so
julie you're retiring what's going to
happen with track software who's going
to carry that forward
and i told them that i'm seeking
emeritus status and my hope is that
i can
bring this software
up
and grow it into
the latest it
this software licenses are distributed
through the center for technology
licensing at cornell university
and there are six iterations of the
software for different crops and it's
also available for turf brass
the next series of slides are just going
to be some screen captures i realize
that these are very retro very old
version of excel but the program still
essentially works the same way
there's a chem table
which now is open so the grower can keep
their own pesticide inventory
with all of the information they need
about these pesticides that they are
using and they can also include the unit
that is applied and the cost for the
available for that particular unit so
their unit
cost the farm spray records are kept on
the spray data sheet
and the farm data is actually populated
on other sheets and it basically
potentiates
drop down lists so that all their
varieties are in the program and they
can choose whichever variety from these
drop-down lists making it really easy to
fill out their spray records
the drop-down lists from the kate from
the chem table populate the pesticide
trade name drop down list and here i'm
going to select diethane
and all of this information is going to
fill in automatically simply by ch
selecting that trade name
and then if they know the cost
and they know how much they've applied
which obviously they do
the program calculates the cost of that
application for them per acre and after
releasing track apple i can remember a
grower from the champlain valley coming
into my office saying julie
track apple is great
but you know what
the person in my office doesn't believe
that i actually spent seven thousand
dollars on sovereign this year
but actually they had
so
pesticides are expensive
and they don't just apply them for any
old reason
the other thing this does is it fills
out the uscpa worker protection standard
form
everything here in these columns is
required but track goes a step further
and calculates the safe re-entry date
and re-entry time
for the farm workers
here's a processor form that gets filled
out with all of the sprays
and
you know then they can print that out
and send it to their buyer
carrick alluded to nua the network for
environment and weather applications and
i started working on newa and there were
about 45 weather stations mostly around
geneva and in western new york
and during the 11 years that i was
leader we grew the network to over 500
stations in
11 different states and now there are
over 850 weather stations
that are driving plant disease forecasts
insect phenology tools crop management
tools
and weather data tools
we just launched a new device friendly
website
that
renders on your phone just as well as it
renders on a desktop laptop or tablet
computer
and the thing i'm most excited about
is when you've got 850 weather stations
and all these state partners
you know that you have a lot of weather
stations and locations to sort through
if you're a user
so the user can set up a new a dashboard
with the tools they want
from the weather stations they want
they set up their login number one they
set up their profile number two
and number three this shows the
dashboard
with the current conditions at that
weather station the forecast and also
a summary of the result from the
forecast tool that shows up on their
dashboard
and so you guys can go up go on to newa
and set up your own dashboard for things
that you want to see
it's as easy as one two three
and we did a
survey of noah in 2017. this is pretty
exciting
so on average the growers responding to
this survey are saving 4 300
per year
from reducing pesticide sprays
33 000 per year by preventing crop loss
and their average annual per acre
savings
was estimated by the people in this
survey to be two thousand one hundred
dollars
all the growers agreed strongly
or agreed period
that nua
can reduce sprays
improve spray timing
inform them about pest risk and enhance
their ipm practices
and the key really cool thing this shows
you all of the new apple models that we
currently have for insects
uh crop management and diseases
and what two were the most often used
hey carrick look at this fire blight and
apple scab
so pretty awesome
every survey respondent that was using
newa currently said that they would
recommend newa to other growers so we're
pretty excited about that system for ipm
a research project that i did in ipm
was on bacterial canker of sweet cherry
basically the focus of my work initially
was to determine if the copper sprays
that were being recommended by the
horticulturalists to be applied before
and after pruning
were actually doing anything at all
um
so basically we found out that not only
was copper ineffective at protecting the
pruning cuts but so were phosphite
sprays and carrick helped me on this
phosphite work
um
and we found no difference essentially
in canker progression
down a pruning stub
with these sprays we did find
the use of pruning stubs
actually protected the trunks of the
trees and the scaffolds
that those
limbs were attached to
they protected them from canker invasion
and leaving pruning stubs is now
standard practice in new york cherry
orchards not only sweet cherry but also
tart cherry even though tart cherry is
much less susceptible to this disease
caused by pseudomonas ringi pathovars
suringi and morse prunorum
we looked at the timing of pruning
and we found that pruning after harvest
was the best timing and reduced canker
progression the most and you can see
that on this chart
here is the july post-harvest pruning
treatment
and the extent of canker
in centimeters
and this is the march
april and may pruning timings
here you can see a picture of a stub
pruned in march
the canker has progressed down
this far
and one pruned in july after harvest and
the canker has progressed really not
very far at all
and we wanted to make sure that it
wasn't
uh something that like next spring
wasn't going to carry over
so we actually flagged those and
measured them again in spring of the
following year
obviously a grower that is leaving stubs
wants to make sure that that's not just
going to become blind wood so we looked
at whether those stubs would produce new
lateral growth and indeed all of them do
which was great
but interestingly enough 2009 being a
wetter year
those stubs that were pruned in march
and april had a greater proportion
of the laterals
dying
from
infection as shown in the numbers in
parentheses
finally a little bit here about on my
work on actually there's is one more
slide sorry so this really isn't finally
but close we're getting close
snow cover and ascos for maturity
was an area that i
investigated kind of as a as a
retrospective
when i first started in the ipm program
squash mounts to determine whether aspen
spores of venturi and equalis were
mature
or not
was a common technique
and there was argument
and differences of opinion as to whether
this type of technique really should go
forward
um it is fraught with error
uh because of the subjective nature of
the test and it is difficult to do
because you have to have an unsprayed
susceptible orchard and have screened
little mesh bags of leaves
that can overwinter that you can select
from to look at the pseudothesia
developing in the leaf litter but i was
doing this and
that first year
i found something very striking
normally
ascospores mature sometime around green
tip green tip of the floral buds on
apples
i was finding mature aspaspores at
silver tip
and some of those buds were dormant even
it was snowing when i had gone out to
collect the leaves
and there had been a lot of snow cover
that spring
so i asked wayne wilcox who was the tree
fruit pathologist at the time i said you
know could this be related to the snow
cover and he said i don't know but i've
got nine years of biological data you
could take a look at so we took a look
at those nine years of biological data
and compared them
to
ask us for maturity predicted by the
degree day model for
pseudothesial development
ascal development and ascospor
development
that uses green tip as the biofix
and we've got snow cover data for geneva
and we compared all of these data
and we found that in five out of nine
years when there was snow cover present
the pathogens biology was advanced as
can be seen in this slide by this blue
line
far ahead
of what was predicted by the model
shown by this pink line
and these dotted lines are the 95
percent confidence interval for that
model
the green bars
indicate the snow events that year
and this green arrow indicates the first
ascospores found in the spore release
tower
and in the other years
when there was no snow cover
basically we saw that the biological
data
pretty closely matched
the degree day model prediction
and this is what we're looking at we're
looking at these pseudothesia developing
inside the leaves that produce inside
them these acid
and the venturi and equal ascospores
that are forcibly ejected
and then infect the green tissues
in the spring
if a grower has one scab lesion on an
apple
the value of that apple is one-tenth
the value of a fresh apple without a
scab lesion
so you can see that the economics of
that system are pretty severe
lastly i'll talk about my work on
hummingbirds and drosophila suzuki eye
d suzuki eye or spotted wing drosophila
is a little teeny fruit fly
that has the ability to deposit eggs in
perfect delicious fruit
and the resulting larvae or maggots
basically feed in that fruit and make it
look like this it literally drips off
the receptacle of the fruit
or like this and you can see the
receptacle stained with the red
raspberry juice here's the male fly
and you can see he has a spot at the tip
of each wing thus the common name
spotted wing drosophila
we wanted to find out whether we could
attract ruby-throated hummingbirds into
raspberry fields and whether that would
have a measurable
impact on
d suzuki eye abundance as measured by
trap counts
and egg laying as measured by fruit
infestation
we attracted the ruby-throated
hummingbirds with feeders and we found
yes we can definitely attract them into
our research plots
and in both
sets of experiments in these plots the
second year 2016 and 2018
saw more ruby-throated hummingbirds
visiting the planting then in the
first year when we set the feeders there
august
was the month that had greatest
abundance of hummingbirds as well
we found numerical reductions in trap
counts and fruit infestation these are
the fruit infestation charts and you can
see the feeder treatment and the black
bar
sorry the no feeder treatment in the
black bar and the feeder treatment in
the gray bar
this gray box indicates when
hummingbirds were most abundant
in that field
and here you can see cumulative
fruit infestation without feeders and
the cumulative level
of infestation with feeders
we found in terms of hummingbird
behavior
that 81
across the four years on average 81
of the behaviors of these birds around
the feeders had predatory potential in
other words they were spending time in
the raspberry plantings they weren't
just flying out of the field to the
feeder and then back out again they were
actually residing in the raspberry
plantings while they were
feeding on the
sugar solution in the feeders
and as predators hummingbirds may have
an ecology of fear effect on d suzuki
which would reduce further
feeding by the insects and their
egg-laying activities
am retiring
and i'm happy to say that my position in
ipm is going to be available soon i
believe this job announcement is going
to go out this week
so please contact alejandro palixto the
new york state ipm director if you are
interested in this position tell your
graduate students and post docs about it
it does require a phd in plant pathology
entomology and horticulture
i would love it if another plant
pathologist got this job
and uh
you know it's a great
great program to work with
with that i want to just express special
thanks to everybody here and to everyone
who has contributed to the success of my
programs and the impact of my work over
the years
and if there's time i'll uh entertain
any questions you might have thanks so
much all right thank you for a wonderful
presentation julie that was really nice
if you
excuse me if you have questions please
post them in the chat and or raise your
hand i will do
chat questions first but if i don't see
them i'll take a hand like the one from
keith
hello juliet thanks for the talk great
fun i saw your
discussion of the um
your time as diagnostic
diagnostician uh in the 80s
and those numbers of plant specimens
that you were showing and it it reminded
me that sometimes diagnosis
diagnosticians can be overwhelmed by the
numbers of samples and i and entertain
themselves by uh creating names for some
of them and i was wondering if you
wanted to share with
some of the community the names you had
for the the massive numbers of geraniums
that you got or the turf
[Music]
turf plugs that would come in in large
numbers and secondarily with regards to
diagnostics i'm just wondering your view
of diagnostics
40 years later and how
that information will be delivered to
people versus in the time in the past
particularly with
less support for diagnostic
clinics and positions and greater
availability of information on the
internet so any comment on that
yeah sure i apologize for my landline
ringing in the back uh oh good it
stopped okay great so the geraniums as
you know i called derangiums
because we often uh during geranium
propagation time in march really did
feel like we were going insane
um the turf grass samples i always you
know they would bring in these plugs and
i i really always wanted to set up a
barbie in her golf
attire
on those and put it on display in one of
those glass cases in the main hall in
plant science but i never
actually did and i think it's because i
didn't have the proper golf attire for
my barbie uh at the time
but my technician when i when i when
that picture was taken my my summer
technician work study student
um liked to make those little post-it
note like golf
flags for the for the label for those um
in terms of diagnostics today
you know the the really exciting thing
are the the molecular tests that are
available that just really make it so
much easier to pinpoint what you're
dealing with
um
i would take some of my fusarium
isolates to uh
hans fennetten's research lab and have
him do a mating cross so that i would
know if it was solanai or not
um i would take samples to so you know
researchers beware i knew what you were
working on um but i'd take
some samples to uh peter palakitis to do
dot plots for me or
there was an electron microscopy lab and
you know they could do a dip test to see
if there were virions in that
now you've got all these
you know rapid assays
for a lot of these pathogens
and i can remember um bob dickey's
technician kathy i can't remember
kathy's last name
she went on to work for steve beer and i
can remember her saying zoom off i was
what
zoom off
zoom off yes kathy said i can't believe
how easy it is to identify
bacteria
with you know pcr i don't have to do all
these chemical tests anymore
so um yeah i think streamlining of
diagnosis is by far
in a way
much much easier but at the same time
you are more
accessible to more people
uh with email and i know sandy has told
me the number of emails they get in is
just it's really staggering
oh
yeah
can i all right
go ahead gillian
for a second yeah
thank you julie um
love the hummingbird story as always uh
we are going to miss you but
you're not going far
and
um i appreciate your comments about
then and now
regarding women
it's so much easier now but it's still
not quite there is it
nope
i
i think it's scary to take an implicit
bias test i i will say that even for
myself
um
i will say that in my mind
doctors are all men
for the most part and i really have to
work on that it's implicit bias and i
really really hope
that
a hundred years from now that will not
be the case
but even just yesterday
i was heading off to my doctor's
appointment
and my husband said well
i hope he doesn't find anything wrong
and i said she
she
so
yeah um i mean
it really
it
it was it was
it was different being the only woman in
staff meeting
and
often well not even often when i started
the youngest
person in those staff meetings
[Music]
i'm glad that has changed i really
really am
how am i
another question
oh there are some chats my gosh there
are ten chat questions
well they're most of them are just like
um accolades and thank yous but we do
have one from um
jess um
any tips uh what to expect lists or
you'd like to give the current graduate
students and postdocs that are planning
to dive into the ipm world that sounds
like a fantastic question julie thoughts
okay so if you want to get into the ipm
world
a lot is getting into the mind of the
grower
i can remember wayne wilcox telling me
when i first started you know the
faculty in ipm are about the closest
to being a grower of any faculty member
on this campus and it's true because you
have to you have to be aware of every
pest
you know from deer
eating an orchard to
you know coddling moth getting into the
fruit
and at the larvae of the cobbling moth
um to scab
um although that honeycrisp is for the
most part resistant to scabs so it's a
pretty easy scab management thing but
the whole the whole thing is trying to
think like a grower
about what their challenges are
and recognize
that they know a heck of a lot more
about growing fruit than you do
but your expertise
on the side of plant pathology
far outweighs theirs and they need that
and they want that information from you
that that would be my recommendation and
hey jess if you're interested in
applying for the job i'd love to chat
with you more about it um
you know reach out to me
for sure
all right other
other questions or anyone want to just
unmute and say anything nice i'm sure
julie will take those as well
yeah oh some people just seem to really
enjoy say the talk it was a lot of fun
it's a great career the relative
humidity work on on grapevine powdery
mildew that's that's my phytopathology
paper
i think it's uh what was it i think it
was like it's been cited 122 times i
don't know if that means anything or not
i'm not i'm very extension oriented
people so i don't really uh talk in
terms of citation indices and that type
of thing so i apologize
very cool all right um we can still take
accolades and if you want to um all you
know react
positively
you know go ahead click your reaction
buttons thank you again julia it's
fantastic talk i will leave the zoom
open if anyone wants to
continue you know talking and sharing
things but as far as students go you
have gotten your credit for the day
thank you
excellent
i'm glad i contributed to that for you
guys
great well thank you all for coming i
really appreciate it
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu